ma secondo me si possono usare per gli
occhi sono rincorse benvenuti in un
nuovissimo video come potete notare sono
in una tenuta particolare e molto
pittoresca molto da pittrice perché non
vi ho mai svelato che io nasco pittrice
ma mira invento youtuber quindi il mio
talento originario è la pittura si sono
molto brava dipingere tant'è che ho
detto non solo voglia dipingere un
quadro per il mio mariners
ma lo farò bendata per fare ciò vi
serviranno poche e semplici cose una
tela uno strato di carta per evitare che
marina faccia danni sul muro dei
pennelli
la tavolozza dove andremo a collocare
colori che sono di lameri sono
dimenticati e ovviamente una mascherina
ok ci siamo vi sto per bendare
incrociamo le dita che vada tutto bene
avrete già paura di fare disastri a casa
dove sono i pennelli
più avanti ok sento ok ok la tavolozza
cielo i colori poi qua c'è il bianco e
nero dove l'acqua il verde mi serve
dov'è qua scendo e verde ok ok
così non va bene ma devo dipingere anche
dentro dove dipingo dentro
qui dove qui qui più vero fino a qua
fino a qui
così siamo aiutati non è proprio colore
dato tutto e dove devo andare
qui così si senta qui sono sporcati qua
[Risate]
perché lì ok
dai amori far disastri qui quindi adesso
che a fare le palline di natale che sono
rosse e mi ricordo che il rosso era il
secondo valore qui qui si sa se telai
divisa voglio che venga bene quasi 26
secondo me devo cambia tenerlo perché
bossi sono più piccoli quindi qui qui
qui e i balocchi
anzi facciamo le lucine così vado
come visto che ho già il giallo che
quello questo farei anche la stella
cometa dai come venuta dov'è qui e devo
col dov'è qui si da coloro edoardo va di
moda il concettuale fini anche se non
divido dal rosso quali esatto e rometta
qua esatto e poi giallo vicino quel
giallo si è quel bianco che il primo
va bene e cosa faccio la faccia ok e poi
vabbò natale ha la barba bianca però
devo cambiare pennello perché è più
piccola quindi il bianco e qui giusto no
ora faccio il vestito rosso qui a
portare un po più a sinistra
qui che è un po più giù qui
[Musica]
così il corpo e dirvi dove che faccio
cappello qui cappello il cappello di
babbo natale li così è il pon pon lo
devo fare bianco quindi devo ripagare
quando è lui quanto babbo natale la
barba essere suo fianco come caduto
bianco per terra
se vuoi fare la barba e il pon pon del
cappello e il cappello
cosi perche chieda che bello poi
dobbiamo fare ln quindi ho bisogno del
marrone o cambiare pennello perché ho
bisogno
dov'è il marrone ragazzi di pentole
marrone perché loro mi sta componendo e
qui e qui e dov'era il bravo e questo
top seccato qui è dove lui qui è e dov'è
il babbo natale sotto la parata l'eroe
sicuramente la scusa è qui qui sotto è
libero gelati dai questa è la renna
allora qui c'è una renna
poi dovremo fare altro per questioni di
spazio ne facciamo
ah sì e allora dov'è di mi dove il
marrone e ne facciamo un'altra
sull'altro qui
così può fare i regali regali dimmi dove
il rosso qui qui qui e qui c'è spazio
qui vado
i ragazzi è difficilissimo perché non
come potete notare la pena si muove
perché qua non è che siamo in una
galleria d'arte siamo in camera di
marina e cioè la tena che si muove è
giusto e vero giallo
facciamo un pacco oro qua si no così
così
ok
e poi ci sono i regali cosa c'è anche a
natale i bue e l'asinello perché ho
voglia di fare a disegnare animali qua
faccia dove dimmidove vuoto perché io
non c'è un caso allora tutto a sinistra
tutto sinistro insomma occhiata qui si
sono chiuse quindi qui facciamo il bue
e qua facciamo no la sea nello così così
questo è un asinello
va beh io prendo un colore a caso e
faccio una scritta e coloro preso verde
e dove era vuoto
dove posso farla questa allora devo fare
sull'albero e al qui
qui si sa ancora dove dirvi ancora va
bene ok dai veramente cosa ben è
importante che sia concettuale salvo
natale
questo è il nero il nero loro scrivere
marina come si fa qui la firma dove non
è quasi qui a vuoto si recita un attimo
che devo tenerlo fermo con il suo quadro
e ballerino qua cosi top no scritto
scusa ma in che cosa si legge i drive
dai punti di vista quella parte rino dei
puntini caratteristici che dan che sono
il cielo stellato a dubai e poi dritto
fino al mattino allora ragazzi come
faccia così si madonna rivedere la luce
stranissimo 3 2 1 posso dire una cosa
ok non si capisce niente ma secondo me è
molto concettuale
questo è sembra un angelo cevolo far
babbo natale ma in realtà questo qui non
venivi sembra un vestito resti bisogna
saperli leggere i quadri e queste sono
le ali
adesso visto che comunque la firma non è
dovuta benissimo è piaciuto soprattutto
vedere io firmerei
[Musica]
marina equa scrivo anche mariners bello
non è bellissimo ragazzi che dire
ragazzi non è stato facile è stata
veramente un'impresa quest'idea malata
non so dove mi sia venuta ma è stato
comunque divertente grazie per l'aiuto
edoardo se non forse avrei disegnato le
tende e comunque al suo perché al suo
perché perché è molto concettuale come
piace a me e molto arte moderna anche
qualche nota di picasso e mirò appenderò
qui in camera come potete vedere io vi
mando un bacio enorme spero che questo
video vi sia piaciuto abbia fatto
sorridere perché io mi son divertito
molto falla e niente ci vediamo la
prossima puntata di mariners atac
[Musica]